Hôm qua 1.2 năm, ngày hủ chăm 20 xấu, buồn tên nạn tại Cô Bộ Một Bê, tình thánh quyền, khiến Trung táaló hòn 2 hí sinh đã trở thành tâm điểm chuyến,
dựa trên giữ lợi camera hàng trình và kênh lận từ các quan trích nằm, sự việc sế xát tại khu vực đường dọc tâm nghiên thoáng,
tổ công tác đăng thực hiện dệ vụ đúng quy chính. Mình nhân chức tiếp là ZOL-C-124,
2 một một bệnh sảo thiếu qua xát không làm chú tất độ và có cố đánh lại từ thần sau phải khi trên đối.
Mọi là điều át í trên hoảng sau hội điều là sự xuyên tạo phố cân cứ, ít ai biết rằng chức khi hí sinh,
Trung táaló hòn 2 luôn là một chiến sĩ hết mình vì như dân. Hình anh anh giẫn đường cho xe cấp biểu dưới sống xe đường đúc để ki thời kí quay đã tự lấy đậm biết bảo chả tiền.
Anh hí sinh khi đang lỗ lục ngăn chẳng như hùng thình xa lộ, chính là những phục tính gây ra những vụ vì phạm về nụ độ côn,
quá tại trong mỗi hại để bảo vệ sự biến ít trong mỗi xa đình khi xa đường.
Tất hoặc những đồ đăng tình trạm đến, nha...
Tất hoặc đường đường đường đường đường đường tục côn, vẫn còn những cá nhân đi chợ sân,
tháng lên thằng tờ buồn những lời điều lận hà hệ, suo phạm dừng người đã hốt.
Thầm chí, có những cá nhân bất chấp đạo lý để kuy cơ chơi sử hí sinh của một con người đang bảo vệ mình ít cho chính họ.
Tự sông, luôn lận không đồng ý với sự vụ giáo dục, mạng là áng,
nhưng lỗi đồng và chiến nhiệm pháp lý là thật.
Phong án đing mạng và phòng, chúng tôi phạm sự dụng công nghệ cao,
không án tình thấy nguyên đã vào cuộc sử liên nghiêm các triệu hợp này.
Mối cả một cạnh sách xa thông át xuống đều để lại phía sau một máy ấm săng dự,
nhé lưới trẻ đợi cho vệ.
Chúc khi có một dòng bình lợt, hãy dừng lại một dịp để nghĩ về đạo lý con người,
hãy cùng nhau là tỏ hình ảnh đẹp với người chiến sĩ để đề lùi bóng tối của sử vụ không.